so the big news that broke late friday
is that indeed
twitter has banned donald trump
permanently from its platform we're
going to go through the decision that
twitter made and then talk about the
implications
twitter putting out a statement saying
after close review of recent tweets from
the trump account
and the context around them specifically
how they're being received and
interpreted on and off twitter
we have permanently suspended the
account due to the risk of
further incitement of violence in the
context of horrific events this week
we made it clear on wednesday that
additional violations of the twitter
rules
would potentially result in this very
course of action
our public interest framework exists to
enable the public to hear from elected
officials and world leaders directly
it is built on a principle that the
people have a right to hold power to the
account to account in the open
however we made it clear going back
years that these accounts are not above
our rules entirely
and cannot use twitter to incite
violence among other things
we will continue to be transparent
around our policies
and their enforcement now reportedly
when this happened
the word being used is ballistic trump
went ballistic
at the white house when he was banned
from twitter a senior administration
said that when twitter permanently took
down trump's account
um trump was scrambling trying to figure
out what to do
initially trump started tweeting through
the official potus account now the potus
account is an account that
is in the hands of whoever is president
so it's not trump's account
it's it's trump has access to it while
being president
that has been shut down trump then tried
tweeting
through one of his aides or staffers
that was shut down
and the president reportedly running
around the white house
going absolutely crazy this the white
house then put out a statement
saying trump is negotiating with other
sites
and looking at building his own platform
and blah blah blah blah blah
so there's a there's a number of
different important things we have to
talk about here
first of all there's lots of really bad
arguments being made
by people on the right and people
on the left including that twitter
shouldn't be allowed
to do this either because they are
silencing only right-wing voices
which is untrue or because trump is
president of the united states
the uh guidelines are already a lower
bar
for world leaders twitter has said and
it was even implicit in the the
statement they put out
twitter has said that when one is a
world leader
they err on the side of not taking
content down and not
banning because they've determined and i
agree with their determination that
it is important for us to know what
world leaders are saying
uh however we would expect our elected
officials to be held to a higher
standard than the average twitter user
with two followers sending me hate
tweets right
like in other words it's
counterintuitive that
world leaders some of the most powerful
people in the world get held to an even
lower standard
merely because they are world leaders
that's been the case all along
twitter is a business that is allowed to
have terms of service and they're
allowed to enforce it
but consider the greater hypocrisy that
many on the right
are now essentially arguing americans
have
an inalienable right to be able to tweet
any limitation on their ability to tweet
is unconstitutional
it's a violation of rights granted by
you know god the constitution who knows
and by the way there's no right to
health care health care is a product
that should be bought and sold on the
free market if you can afford it
but you cannot be restricted
in your ability to tweet give me a break
guys these people have been pathetic for
a very long time
don jr then coming out and saying whoa
we have to do something about the
market monopoly power of twitter
where are we on antitrust well look at
your dad uh i have been out there
for years saying we are not and we've
done multiple interviews
we are not dealing seriously with
the uh antitrust law that we have
and we have not enforced it i've been
talking about that for years
but all of a sudden the day trump's
banned from twitter
don jr cares about monopoly power give
me a break
guys so uh the the truth is trump's
account should have been
uh removed long ago there should be a
higher standard on elected officials not
a lower standard and trump
got away with it this long but now there
is sort of this deluge there's for lack
of a better term these massive dumps of
bans and suspensions that are coming now
since the riotous insurrection now a
cautionary message
despite my belief that this is the right
thing to do
based on trump's use of twitter and
incitements to violence and defense of
the rioters
despite the fact that we're saying it
was correct to ban
trump 12 days before he leaves office
forever
this is a sign of how much we've failed
as a country over the last four years to
control donald trump and to hold
accountable the people who defended him
the rats leaving the sinking ship now
betsy devos
william barr republican senator pat
toomey who now says trump should go
chris christie who now says trump should
be impeached
they are right yes sure but we're 12
11 10 now nine days out as they are
doing these things they do not deserve
to have their images rehabilitated
and we're going to talk about that after
the break but we will have more coverage
of the trump twitter ban and social
media implications
on our instagram where you can find us
at david pakman show
and you can find me on instagram as well
at david.pacman
start your day and your new year off
right with
just egg which is one of our sponsors
you've heard me talk about the
importance of having a diet that is
more heavily plant-based than it's
something i've done
over the last few years i've always
loved eggs so it's great
that there is a delicious plant-based
version of egg with all the protein of
egg that just egg brings with it but
it's made from
mung beans so it uses 98 percent less
water
and causes 93 fewer carbon emissions
than a conventional egg
and just egg cooks and tastes exactly
like
a conventional egg i've tried it for
omelets
scrambled eggs french toast banana bread
pad thai anything you'd normally use
eggs for and i actually think if i
cooked something for a friend without
telling them about just egg
they wouldn't even know the difference
find it in the egg
aisle at your grocery store on amazon
prime now
or on instacart and they also have a
frozen version
perfect for breakfast sandwiches just
egg try it out